ok let's get into cubic so we're going
to solve this X cube minus 6x squared
plus 7x plus 4 equals 0 I came up with
this equation myself so that it would
have nice numbers and that took a lot of
effort to do you saw how complicated the
formulas were so making everything work
difficult so we've got a billion see
there first thing we do we let X equal Y
minus 1/3 a so we've got X here we make
a substitution if we have X is equal to
Y minus that the answer that's x equals
y plus 2 for this particular one and
then we substitute then we get that
equation which doesn't look like much of
an improvement okay now to solve that
well obviously we've got some explaining
to do the cubic one gets the binomial
theorem treatment perfect square they're
basic basic
we expand a bit by bit we get there's
our cubic part there's our quadratic
part there's our linear part and our
constant what do you notice
two things to notice one important one
y-squared is gone that was the point
that's always possible okay
that substitution of x equals y minus
1/3 a will always get rid of the
quadratic term so out of the Mist arises
the depressed cubic equation okay so now
we've got this we started with that we
made a substitution we did the expanding
and simplifying we got that is that any
better they were to graph side by side
it didn't occur to me until quite
recently that of course ones just a
translation of the other all right we've
just we've shifted it by to wear ship
did it to the right by third a alright
and a was negative in this case they
were shifted it like so there's the
original this a new one and so that
means if we can solve the red one we can
solve the purple one now in history
people weren't graphing these things
people didn't even have negative numbers
Co when the geometry was yet to arrive
so this talk is blending historical and
modern ideas Sarah and I need to
apologize I've done a lot of research on
this not primary research for just
reading various things I build up an
idea in my mind and then I read
something that contradicts something and
yeah so I can't promise that everything
is historically accurate but I do
believe it's more important to be
interesting than correct